عندما يتعلق الأمر بفيروس كورونا ، فإن معرفة كيفية
انتشاره يمكن أن يساعد في وقف الانتشار
ولهذا السبب تعاون الباحثون في
جامعة إيموري مع مركز السيطرة
على الأمراض لدراسة كيفية تحرك الفيروس في
أماكن مثل المدارس والرعاية النهارية
التي وجدوا أن الأسطح
مصدر مهم للمخاطر
بشكل خاص.  مثل الأشياء غير المسامية
مثل المناضد أو
الألعاب البلاستيكية ، على سبيل المثال ، بن لوبمان هو
المؤلف الرئيسي للدراسة التي قالها
الأستاذ في مدرسة إيموري رولينز
للصحة العامة إن
التنظيف المتكرر مهم حيث
يقضي الناس
وقتًا أطول بكثير كما هو الحال في المدرسة كما هو الحال في
الرعاية النهارية  أو
مكان مكتب حيث يمكن للأشخاص إذا كان
شخص ما معديًا أن يستمروا في
تلويث السطح ، فإن التنظيف المتكرر مطلوب
ولكن في المدارس يقول إنه حتى التنظيف كل ساعة
قد لا يوفر حماية كافية
، كما يقول ، فإن أفضل طريقة لتقليل المخاطر
هي تجنب تلويث تلك الأسطح
في البداية  وضع أشياء مثل ارتداء القناع
هو وسيلة رائعة لتجنب التلوث
مع عدم وجود
لقاح حاليًا  زد للأطفال
يقول لوبمان إنه من المهم أكثر من أي وقت مضى
احتواء فيروسات كورونا المنتشرة
في المدارس ويهتم يوميًا بالصحة ،
فأنا ماندي غايثر